la superintendencia de transportes
reporta 61 puntos de tránsito obstruidos
y doce vías nacionales afectadas en puno
la situación que hoy empieza con el
toque de queda en la noche y también
está de duelo se ha visto reflejada con
la movilización de los pobladores
quienes han cargado féretros de las 17
personas que murieron durante la jornada
de lucha de las últimas horas ellos
visitaron algunos puntos de la ciudad y
esto ha sido como una muestra de la
situación de dolor que vive en estos
momentos el sur del Perú Mientras tanto
en cusco los manifestantes se enfrentan
a las fuerzas del orden esta población
trata de tomar por la fuerza el
aeropuerto José Velasco astete Mientras
tanto en Arequipa otra región que
también está en conflicto algunos
pobladores intentan realizar saqueos
mientras que otros tratan de tomar la
Plaza Mayor de esa calidad en la
situación respecto a Lima se encuentra
en tensa calma la capital del Perú se va
a convertir el foco de la atención
porque muchos manifestantes han
anunciado que van a trasladar las
jornadas de protesta a Lima Francisco y
una de las reacciones internacionales
más recientes es la de Estados Unidos
que llamó a la moderación y respalda la
investigación de las muertes pero
también la Comisión Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos inicia una visita que
se sabe de esto
Sí justamente los miembros delegados de
la misión de la Comisión Interamericana
de Derechos Humanos efectuaron su
primera agenda con la presidenta Dina
boluarte y algunos funcionarios de su
gobierno el organismo le ha recomendado
a las autoridades de este país que se
empleen estándares interamericanos de
necesidad y proporcionalidad del uso de
la fuerza y que también se vele por el
respeto de los Derechos Humanos
justamente la presidenta boluarte ha
prometido todas las facilidades la
visita de la misión culmina El Trece de
enero y posteriormente elevará un
informe ante la Corte Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos